Bots Let's
uh ban
that and somebody testing puffer on an
800 now
I go look something up real quick cuz
people are telling me that these H
hundreds are like ridiculously faster or
should be and they're not not from what
we've seen
this oh I see they have on tensor
cores it is a bunch of flops
but
it I'm just checking something real
quick and then we'll do some uh some Dev
on on this
seeing okay
here's
tenser why don't they report T flops
fp32 what's wrong with
them so they have fp32 t flops
82 which is actually more than an
h00 on on the
base and then the tensor
course they don't actually
report uh tf32 T
flops and
from what's this slash
I mean according to this the h00 should
be massively faster but I don't actually
see
that but I've seen how much are 800s
again I mean they're I think they're
also 10 times more than 10 times the
price
right 30 yeah so this
is I mean
regardless I don't actually think you
get that performance ever as the thing
thing for RL
workloads okay so uh what we're going to
do now we're going to go to Puff
fli we're going to try to figure out if
we can get e3b to be stable actually
wrong
Branch oh no right
Branch let's do
this why don't we go get some
nice pong parameters to use from our
sweep as
well we have some very nice pong
parameters I believe
nice simple
environment just to see if this thing is
stable believe it's this sweep right
here that's the 38
second
solve
right yes
hey how's it
going pretty
good I'm working on a few things leaving
on a trip tomorrow so trying to get out
all the work
into you know mostly a good
spot I probably should have filtered
this
time chill trip with a little bit of
work in the evenings because you know
always no this is just P we're getting
us some parameters to do a thing with
trying to figure out which of these I
want to
use cuz like you know these sometimes
you get these like
spikes I'm looking for something that
looks mostly stable
it's actually kind of funny that we have
a like 25 solve here it looks
like you
say I thought it was 38 seconds oh cuz
the whole run is 38 seconds we actually
have it solved it looks like in
um that's like a solve in 25 seconds
but it kind of isn't the most stable
thing in the
world this one looks good this is still
a sub 30 second solve I wish you could
click click the
point that you're
on because I can't see what this
is I can see that this
ends not
great I don't know what I'm supposed to
do with this I guess what we'll do is
we'll
filter to 19 or
whatever hey dude this is supposed to be
a
query stupid
SC now we have something that we can
deal with
maybe much better
and actually I just need to have this
scale a little
better you should be able to figure it
out it doesn't let you scroll over the
so
obnoxious